i am so excited to start this show we're
going to start it with a love letter
um to a legend and we want to honor his
career in entertainment and he continues
to make a huge impact and difference on
the world
and we are celebrating him today it's
donnie osmond
six decades in show business 33 gold
records and over 100 million albums sold
donny osmond is a true entertainment
legend
born in 1957 in ogden utah donnie was
the seventh son in the talented osmond
family at just five years old donnie
made his tv debut on the andy williams
show singing alongside his older
brothers by the 1970s donnie had become
a teenage heartthrob creating mass
hysteria everywhere he went his solo
career started with a hit cover of sweet
and innocent followed by his signature
song puppy love
in the years to follow donnie and his
sister marie would become an unstoppable
musical duo eventually leading to their
own variety show donnie and marie which
ran from 1976 to 1979.
they even performed at the 1981 ronald
reagan presidential inauguration in 1989
donnie returned to the charts with his
hit single soldier of love which went to
number two on the hot 100.
fast forward to 2008 the brother and
sister duo paired up yet again for a
limited six weeks residency in las vegas
the show became such a hit that six
weeks turned into an unprecedented 11
year run fun fact donnie is also the
voice behind the iconic song i'll make a
man out of you from disney's mulan and
the crown champion for season nine of
dancing with the stars it's hard to sum
up an illustrious six decade long career
but it's easy to sum up our love for
this legend
i have been waiting for this please
welcome donny osmond
please have a seat
can i just get a selfie
[Applause]
okay also i wanted to like i just felt
the urge to just make whatever whatever
you know i i grew up with you
um
let's show the clip of you on the andy
williams show at you're five years old
or six five yeah okay let's take a look
at that
[Applause]
that it seems like
it seems like yesterday
that i did that i i i totally relate
yeah it's really strange i don't know if
you go through this too but it's almost
looking like
at a different person
and and a different life but then you
immediately say to yourself but that's
me i remember doing that because there's
been so many different uh reinventions
of my life and so many different careers
that i've gone through
that it's it's like looking at another
person well you can look at it
and then all of a sudden you start to
remember what the looking through it
from the other perspective like do you
remember seeing andy williams with your
own eyes i vividly
i vividly remember walking down from the
audience i was with my dad and he said
go get him and i was walking down i had
no idea the millions of people who were
watching me because i thought you know
it's just a few hundred people in the
studio and i didn't know how many people
were looking through that lens yep
and uh and the funny thing happened so i
did the show and everybody's applaud and
everything worked great
so andy did a christmas tour right after
that because that aired in december of
63
maybe 63
and
it was 1863.
and so my brothers went out on this
christmas tour with andy and everybody
said well where's the little donny kid
we just saw on television so my dad
asked if it was okay if i if my mom at
home with me put me on an airplane
i flew to chicago
and i remember walking out on stage
after he introduced me and the
spotlights hit me i thought there were a
couple hundred people out i didn't know
thousands of people were out there
and so i'm singing my song i can't
remember what i was singing and then all
of these flash bulbs and whistles and
hollering and yelling and clapping and
it scared me so much i ran off stage
and then and it's like it was yesterday
and i remember andy saying donnie come
back out here this is all for you come
take a bow and i remember at that moment
thinking
i got to do this the rest of my life
you have experienced something
most people never will in 1971 you
released your first solo hit sweet and
innocent
and you're all of a sudden on your own
you're not with your family as much
you're front and center it's all for you
as andy says
what was that like
that was hard
it was it's actually
i'm going to use a word that you
probably will be confused that and that
was embarrassing
because the brothers
had started this whole thing and i
joined as an afterthought
and they kept pushing me forward i
didn't want it i was really a shy kid
i didn't want to be pushed forward and
it was it was a little embarrassing is
it that you're thinking oh god please i
don't do this to my family dynamic i
want to be equal to everyone i don't
want to make this an issue within our
family and that's exactly what these
applause are doing
or is it like what was the feeling well
very cool question
yes to a certain extent but on the other
side i was having a blast all these
girls scream in your name it's like what
guy wouldn't want that you know
it's like
i mean think about that i mean look at
that there's they're chasing they're
trying to get through the cops and the
barriers to get to me it's like yes i
love this life okay so this leads me to
the point where most people will never
experience this
it's
mania there is a famous story actually
that really grabbed my attention when
you went to heathrow airport the fans
came in such droves
that i have chills all over my body
right now telling the story that the
balcony broke under the weight of the
fans
and they wouldn't let you fly into
heathrow anymore i was banned from
heathrow
yeah they said okay if donnie osmond's
on the plane it's not landing in
heathrow and they made you go to
scotland and take a trip
and sometimes we went and we took a
train a secret train and that's how i
got into london okay what is it like to
live inside the body and the mind of
literally beetle maniac pretty darn cool
i know that's how i feel like there's so
much in my life i wouldn't trade for a
thing
it was there was one time i was sitting
in the hotel room with my brother alan
and we were watching this uh this the
show there were three people there was
uh the the
the emcee of the show the host of the
show excuse me
uh a member of scotland yard
and a child psychiatrist
and the discussion that they were having
is donnie osmond
healthy for our children in this country
my brother alan looked at me he said you
remember this moment which i have i'll
never forget you remember this moment
because this is so darn cool
and it really was
[Music]
you